نتواجد في منطقه تل الزعتر هنا في مخيم
جبال يتمكنا من الوصول لهذه المنطقه بعد
حصار اليات الاحتلال وقوات الاحتلال لهذه
المنطقه لاكثر من 20 يوم نشاهد هنا جرائم
ارتكبها الاحتلال بحق المواطنين عشرات
الشهداء على الارض في الشوارع كما نشاهد
هنا عشرات الشهداء على الارض هنا في
الشوارع ايضا حجم الدمار الذي هذه المنطقه
كبير جدا كما نشاهد هنا الشهداء في كل
مكان في الشوارع في الطرقات لم تتمكن
الطواقم الطبيه من الوصول لهذه الاماكن
بسبب حصار قوات الاحتلال لهذه المنطقه عدد
كبير من الشهداء هنا في
الشوارع هذه المنطقه دمرها الاحتلال
بالكامل لا يمكن وصف هذا المشهد الشهداء
في كل
[موسيقى]
مكان هنا الدمار طال هذه المدارس في محيط
مستشفى
الاندونيسي
من هذا المكان حاولت اليات الاحتلال
التقدم الى مخيم
جباليا الى عمق المخيم قامت بحفر شارع
بالكامل هنا من وسط مستشفى الاندونيسي ومن
ثم ومن ثم محاوله الدخول الى منطقه تل
الزعتر
هنا الدمار طال المنازل وطال الشوارع وطال
البنيه التحتيه الان هذه المنطقه اصبحت
غير صالحه للسكن بسبب هذا الدمار الكبير
كما
نشاهد نحن نتجه الان الى مستشفى العوده
هذا
المستشفى الذي كان محاصر لاكثر من ع ايام
هنا والاحتلال قام باعتقال مدير هذه
المستشفى هنا وايضا اعتقال عدد من الكوادر
الطبيه وارتكاب مجزره في هذه المنطقه وبحق
مستشفى
العوده اللي حصل انه الحصار
بدا 18 يوم ممنوع حد يتحرك ولا يطلع ولا
يجي اي حد تحرك بزل تحت كانوا بخوه اخذ
الدكتور احمد بات عنده ليله ثاني يوم اجا
قال بدي من 20 ل 40 سنه يطلعو لي 20 20
بالبكسرات طل اول 20 قعدوا اجوا يطلعوا
العشين الثاني قال خلاص بديش روحوا اخذوا
معهم الدكتور احمد مره ثانيه رجعوا ثاني
يوم ثاني يوم كان مم الدكتور احمد واخذ
معه اربعه خمسه من اداريين
المستشفى ورجعوا ايش قال ايش اللي بدكم
اياه قال بدنا من 16 سنه فما فوق الكل
رجال بالبكسرات من غير شباحات ويطلعوا لنا
20 20 20 طلع تقريبا 86 واحد انا مرق
الجيش الاسرائيلي ودمر المنازل كلها
وهنا بجوارنا مستشفى العوده للولاده فقط
لا غير والنساء هذول الثنتين اللي مطوت
جايات يلدن
على مستشفى العوده وهي زوجها هان كمان مطم
فوق الركام اج الجرافات وده سنهم كلهم وه
م قتلوهم هيه هي جثه وهي جثه وهي ك وهي
كمان جثتين لنساء حوامل كمان
قتلوه بدون رحمه ورفعات الرايات البيض
باق ودهسه الجرافات وتم اطلاق النار عليهم
كلهم
قتلوهم هكذا هو المشهد هنا في منطقه تل
الزعتر بعد محاصره قوات الاحتلال هذه
المنطقه لاكثر من 20 يوم حصار ودمار
وعشرات الشهداء في الطرقات لم تتمكن
الطواقم الطبيه من الوصول اليهم انس
الشريف الجزيره شمال
غزه